it's that great time of year again yes
the great school supply Drive starts
today and Rocky stopped by one of our
local Smith's Food and Drug the sponsors
of the segment to learn how you can help
do you see that folder right there is it
bringing you Nostalgia does it take you
back to elementary school because it
takes me back and that is what we're
doing we're celebrating our elementary
school students our students across
Clark County School District with the
great school supply Drive partnered
Channel 8 and Smith of course sell Chris
with Smith's why is this partnership so
important to the community
um with Smith's we're just more than
just in the grocery business we're in
the people business absolutely and
really we want to um families welcome us
into their neighborhood and we just want
to be part of the community I love that
now let's talk about the school supplies
that we are you know purchasing for our
kids I'm oh my God I smell crayons I
have my backpack on I love this you can
bring your kids in and help and have
them shop with you for the to help their
kids their fellow peers and students so
what are we getting here at the seasonal
aisle definitely I mean you have your
variety of pens pencils notebook paper
highlighters everything that you need to
get started for the school season I love
that you got backpacks thermoses lunch
pails anything you would need and these
are across Clark County I always all the
Smith locations and then what's the
process like when people come in to shop
for their groceries they come into the
aisle grab their school supplies and
then what they just grab their school
supplies and then they bring them up to
the check stand and then tell the
cashier that they are donating their
school supplies for the grade 8 school
supply drive and then they would put
them in the bin there we go up front at
the front of the store okay perfect and
of course you see that big date right
here through the 28th you have till next
Thursday to come in and collect your
supplies and donate and then at the cash
registers what do you guys have here at
your location so here at Sky Canyon
Marketplace we have these set up at
every check stand everything in this
little tote here is under a dollar so
everything that we can get donated out
of these boxes will help our school
children here in Clark County and beyond
that you guys are also helping give food
and lunches to our to our students in
need correct correct we are uh
also donating a dollar fifty at our
checkout stands and this goes to help
feed one in six kids in Clark County I
don't know where they're going to get
their next meal and that's a sad reality
and we're just trying to do our part and
help the community absolutely and then
you know on the other hand school
supplies bring these kids Joy right and
shopping for them brings you Joy too so
come on into your Smith your local
neighborhoods Miss and help our kids of
Clark County School District and last
but not least Chris in the spirit of
school supply season let's pick you a
backpack okay okay I've got mine I've
got mine right here all right which one
are you going for
um I'll go with this guy
I like your style here we go
all right we are ready come on down to
Smith's and get your school supplies for
our kids we'll send it back to you
eight news now is partnering with
Smith's in Las Vegas Honda dealers to
collect school supplies for our
community starting today you can drop
off backpacks folders pencils and other
items to your nearby Smith location or
Las Vegas Honda dealer this runs through
July 28th and there's more information
at
eightnewsnow.com now let's bring in